AINSLEY: THANK YOU SO MUCH,
PETER.
LET’S BRING IN LARA TRUMP,
FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR FOR THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, AND WE
HAVE A BIG ANNOUNCEMENT.
SHE IS A NEW FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
WELCOME TO THE FAMILY, LARA.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU.
AINSLEY: FOR THE FOLKS AT HOME
THAT DON’T KNOW YOU, THEY SEE
YOU AND KNOW YOU’RE MARRIED
TO ERIC AND YOU ALL HAVE THESE
TWO BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN BUT TELL
THEM A LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOUR
LIFE AND WHERE YOU GREW UP, WHAT
YOU’RE LIKE AND WHAT YOU PLAN TO
DO HERE AT FOX.
>> WELL I’M SO EXCITED FIRST OF
ALL TO BE JOINING THE FOX FAMILY
I SORT OF FEEL LIKE I’VE BEEN AN
UNOFFICIAL MEMBER OF THE TEAM
FOR SO LONG, YOU GUYS KNOW IT
WAS KIND OF A JOKE OVER THE PAST
FIVE YEARS I WOULD COME THERE SO
OFTEN THAT THE SECURITY GUARDS
WERE LIKE MAYBE WE SHOULD JUST
GIVE YOU A KEY, SO TO BE A PART
OF THE TEAM I’M SO SO EXCITED,
BUT I GREW UP IN NORTH CAROLINA,
I GREW UP IN NORTH CAROLINA, MY
FAMILY STILL LIVES THERE, I
MOVED TO NEW YORK ABOUT 14 YEARS
AGO AND THAT’S WHEN I MET MY
HUSBAND, ERIC.
I NEVER EXPECTED TO BE PART OF A
FAMILY LIKE THE TRUMP FAMILY,
CERTAINLY NEVER EXPECTED TO HAVE
THE INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY THAT
I HAD, ONE OF THEM, OBVIOUSLY
NOW TO BE PART OF THE FOX NEWS
TEAM, SO I’M SO EXCITED AND SO
HONORED, AND REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO WHAT’S TO COME.
STEVE: INDEED.
ALTHOUGH, I’VE READJUST A COUPLE
OF DAYS AGO, YOU WERE STILL
CONSIDERING RUNNING FOR SENATE
IN NORTH CAROLINA.
>> YEAH, WELL, FOX HAS BEEN
VERY GENEROUS WITH ME AND THEY
HAD SAID LOOK IF THAT’S
SOMETHING THAT YOU ULTIMATELY
DECIDE TO DO THEY ARE GOING TO
WORK WITH ME ON THAT FRONT AND
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYTHING ALL
THE RULES ARE FOLLOWED AND WE DO
EVERYTHING PROPERLY, SO THANK
YOU TO THE FOX TEAM FOR ALLOWING
ME TO HAVE THE POSSIBILITY THAT
THAT’S IN THE FUTURE SO I STILL
HAVEN’T OFFICIALLY MADE A
DECISION, BUT HOPEFULLY SOME
TIME SOON.
BRIAN:  ALL RIGHT SO LET’S MOVE
ON TO ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
YOU’RE VALUABLE IS YOUR POSITION
ON THE BIG STORIES OF THE DAY.
YOU KNOW, DURING THE CAMPAIGN NO
ONE WAS REALLY TALKING ABOUT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION TO A GREAT
DEGREE BECAUSE THE BORDER WAS
PRETTY SETTLED AND THE BIG
DEBATE WAS ON THE WALL AND
FINANCED AND THEY TOOK THAT
MONEY AND THEY AREN’T SPENDING
IT AND TOOK THE WALL BUILT AND
THEY’RE STORING IT OR  DESTROY
ING IT AND NOW WE’RE SEEING AN A
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
THEY EVEN HAVE TO TAKE GUARDS
FROM THE NORTH AND BRING THEM
DOWN TO THE SOUTH.
HERE IS JEN PSAKI TRYING TO
EXPLAIN HER WAY THROUGH WHY IT’S
OKAY FOR KIDS TO COME.
>> AT THIS POINT, IN TERMS OF
ALLOWING ACCESS TO BORDER PATROL
FACILITIES FOR REPORTERS, YOU
ARE BEING LESS TRANSPARENT THAN
THE TRUMP ADMINITRATION.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, CHRIS,
THE TRUMP ADMINITRATION WAS
TURNING AWAY KIDS AT THE BORDER,
SENDING THEM BACK ON THE
TREACHEROUS JOURNEY OR  THEY
WERE RIPPING KIDS FROM THE ARMS
OF THEIR PARENTS.
WE’RE NOT DOING THAT.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO ALLOWING
CAMERAS INTO THE BORDER PATROL
FACILITIES, ABSOLUTELY.
BRIAN:  TREACHEROUS JOURNEY, RIP
PING KIDS FROM PARENTS?
>> YEAH, TOTALLY RIDICULOUS.
OBVIOUSLY NONE OF THAT WAS THE
CASE.
IN FACT, WE HAD THE MOST SECURE
BORDER UNDER MY FATHER-IN-LAW
UNDER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
THAT WE HAVE HAD IN DECADES AND
I THINK THE BEST THING POSSIBLE
IS TO DISCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM
MAKING THAT REALLY DANGEROUS
AWFUL JOURNEY NORTH THROUGH OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS SAID, WELL IF
THEY COME, WE’LL TAKE YOU IN SO
GUESS WHAT’S GOING TO CONTINUE
TO HAPPEN.
YOU’RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
ALL OF THESE CHILDREN, YOU KNOW,
FLOODING OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT IS SO SAD.
IT IS SO HARD TO WATCH, BUT WE
HAVE TO GET THIS UNDER CONTROL.
THIS IS NOT TEAR TO THESE KIDS.
IT’S NOT FAIR TO AMERICANS WHO
ARE FOOTING THE BILL NOW.
$86 MILLION TO PAY FOR HOTEL
ROOMS FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
PEOPLE THAT ARE BREAKING OUR LAW
, COMING TO AMERICA, WE ARE
PAYING $86 MILLION FOR HOTEL
ROOMS.
IT IS TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE, BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE DON’T EXPECT TO SEE THAT
CHANGE BECAUSE THIS SEEMS ALMOST
LIKE IT’S PART OF THE BIDEN PLAN
, SADLY.
STEVE: WELL YOU KNOW, LARA, AS
WE LOOK AT THESE IMAGES THAT
DEAD CRUZ, I THINK, TOOK OVER
THE WEEKEND INSIDE THAT FACILITY
AT DONNA, TEXAS, THEY ARE
HORRIBLE AND OF COURSE WHEN YOUR
FATHER-IN-LAW WAS PRESIDENT THEY
REFERRED TO CONDITIONS MUCH
NICER THAN THAT AS KIDS IN CAGES
, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON’T THINK THE PEOPLE THERE
AND I DON’T THINK THE DEMOCRATS,
FOR THE MOST PART, MIND THOSE
PARTICULAR OVERCROWDED
CONDITIONS BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THAT EVERYBODY IN THAT FACILITY
IS GOING TO WIND UP GETTING
RELEASED INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THEY ARE BEING PROCESSED.
NEXT STOP, ANY TOWN USA SO IT’S
JUST THE PRICE YOU HAVE TO PAY
FOR THEM TO GET INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
>> YEAH, WELL AND IT’S TOTAL
HYPOCRISY YOU BRING UP A GREAT
POINT.
THE WAY THEY COVERED THIS ,
UNDER THE TRUMP ADMINITRATION
VERSUS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
IS TOTAL HYPOCRISY.
WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE FROM THE
FOLKS ON THE LEFT?
WHERE IS AOC DOWN THERE DOING A
PHOTO OP CRYING IN FRONT OF A
WALL BECAUSE I HAVE NEWS FOR HER
IT’S MUCH WORSE RIGHT NOW THAN
IT EVER WAS UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINITRATION YET IT HAS BEEN
CRICKETS FROM THOSE FOLKS AND I
THINK IT TELLS A VERY SCARY
STORY.
THEY KNOW THAT THEY HAVE MILLION
S OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
COMING TO AMERICA.
THEY ARE TRYING TO CHANGE OUR
VOTING LAWS, THEY ARE HOPING ONE
DAY THAT ALL OF THESE FOLKS CAN
GO IN AND VOTE WITH NO ID,
BECAUSE THAT’S ONE OF THE THINGS
IN HR-1 THEY ARE PROPOSING THESE
ARE THEIR NEW VOTERS AND IT IS A
TERRIFYING PROSPECT IF WE LET
EVERYBODY FLEE FLOW OVER OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, GUYS IT IS A
VERY VERY SCARY THING GOING ON.
AINSLEY: I KNOW YOUR
FATHER-IN-LAW WORKED REALLY HARD
TO GET THE VACCINES AND THAT WAS
OPERATION WARP SPEED BUT
DEMOCRAT JOE BIDEN AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION, REFUSE TO GIVE
HIM CREDIT.
WATCH THIS.
>> THERE WAS NO NATIONAL
STRATEGY OR  PLAN FOR
VACCINATIONS.
IN MANY WAYS, WE’RE STARTING
FROM SCRATCH.
>> TWO MONTHS AGO, THE COUNTRY,
THIS COUNTRY, DIDN’T HAVE NEARLY
ENOUGH VACCINE SUPPLY TO
VACCINATE ALL OR   NEAR ALL OF
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
>> DOES FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
NOT DESERVE ANY CREDIT ON
VACCINES?
>> MAKING THE PROGRESS THAT WAS
MADE AND WE’VE SAID THIS
PUBLICLY, THAT WAS MADE ON
THESE VACCINES WAS INCREDIBLE
EFFORTS BY SCIENCE, AND BY
MEDICAL EXPERTS, AND CERTAINLY,
WE HAVE APPLAUDED THAT IN THE
PAST AND WE’RE HAPPY TO
APPLAUD THAT AGAIN.
AINSLEY: BUT THEN THERE’S DR.
FAUCI.
HE’S TAKING CREDIT FOR IT,
LISTEN.
>> WHEN I SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN
NEW YORK CITY, ALMOST OVER
RUNNING OF OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM, IT WAS LIKE OH, MY
GOODNESS, AND THAT’S WHEN IT
BECAME VERY CLEAR THAT THE
DECISION WE MADE ON JANUARY
10 TO GO ALL-OUT AND
DEVELOP A VACCINE MAY HAVE BEEN
THE BEST DECISION THAT I’VE EVER
MADE WITH REGARD TO AN
INTERVENTION AS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE INSTITUTE.
AINSLEY: LARA, WHAT’S YOUR
RESPONSE FOR THAT?
>> WELL IT’S ALMOST HARD TO
WATCH THAT WITHOUT LAUGHING AND
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO DR.
ANTHONY FAUCI, IT WAS
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP AND
OPERATION WARP SPEED THAT
ALLOWED US TO GET TO THIS POINT
RIGHT NOW, WHERE WE HAVE SO MANY
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE VACCINATED
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, WE’RE HEADED
TOWARDS HERD IMMUNITY.
I HAVE BEEN IN THE PRESENCE OF
MY FATHER-IN-LAW.
WHEN HE WOULD GET A CALL FROM
THE FOLKS THAT WERE DEVELOPING
THESE VACCINES AND THEY WOULD
SAY WE DON’T KNOW IF IT’LL BE
READY AND HE WOULD SAY GO BACK
TO WORK, WE NEED THIS VACCINE,
WE NEED A SAFE, EFFECTIVE
VACCINE TO GET AMERICA BACKUP
AND RUNNING SO I DON’T
KNOW SORT OF WHAT FANTASY LAND
DR. FAUCI WAS LIVING IN BUT IT
WAS UNDER THE DIRECT DIRECTION
OF PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP THAT
WE GOT THESE VACCINES AND THANK
GOD WE DID, BECAUSE AMERICA IS
FINALLY STARTING TO COME BACK.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO
FEEL LIKE THIS NIGHTMARE MIGHT
BE OVER BUT I GIVE FULL A AND 10
COMPLETE PRESIDENT TO PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP.
BRIAN:  SO LARA, CAN YOU GIVE US
AN IDEA OF WHAT’S GOING ON IN
MAR-A-LAGO?
WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT GAVE AN
IMPROMPTU SPEECH AT A WEDDING
OVER THE WEEKEND, HAD A TUX ON
AND TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
POLITICS AND WE ALSO KNOW HE’S
CONSIDERING GOING DOWN TO THE
BORDER.
HE SAYS HE’S BEEN ASKED TO GO IN
THE NEXT TWO WEEKS.
IS HE GETTING, ARE YOU GETTING
THE SENSE THAT HE’S GETTING SET
TO RUN AGAIN?
>> WELL, I’LL LEAVE THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT UP TO HIM IF THAT’S
SOMETHING HE ULTIMATELY DECIDES
TO DO, BUT IT’S REALLY HARD, I
THINK, TO SEE SORT OF THE
DISASTER THAT HAS ENSUED
SINCE JOE BIDEN TOOK OFFICE.
WHENEVER YOU SET THINGS UP SO
WELL, AND STAY SILENT, SO I KNOW
THE BORDER PATROL WANTS TO HAVE
MY FATHER-IN-LAW COME DOWN TO
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
I MEAN, HE WAS THE PERSON THAT
REALLY TURNED THINGS AROUND DOWN
THERE, AND REALLY GOT US IN SUCH
A BETTER SPOT WITH ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND AMERICA.
HE DID GIVE A SPEECH AT A
WEDDING, ERIC AND I WERE THERE
OVER THE WEEKEND.
HE WAS SO HAPPY TO BE THERE, BUT
LOOK, HE IS DOING WHAT HE FEELS
HE NEEDS TO DO.
HE’S STANDING UP AND CONTINUING
TO SPEAK OUT
FOR THE 75 MILLION-PLUS
AMERICANS THAT VOTED FOR HIM.
HE HAS NOT FORGOTTEN ABOUT THEM.
THEY WILL NOT BE LEFT BEHIND BY
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP, AND
QUITE FRANKLY IT’S ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT I’M SO HAPPY
NOW TO BE PART OF THE FOX FAMILY
, BECAUSE I HOPE EVERY
SINGLE DAY I CAN REPRESENT THEM,
HERE ON FOX AND YOU KNOW, MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE TRANSPARENT
BECAUSE QUITE FRANKLY, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT.
WE NEED TO CALL THEM OUT FOR
THEIR FAILURES.
MY FATHER-IN-LAW WILL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT AND I WILL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT HERE ON FOX.
STEVE: THAT’S RIGHT PEOPLE SAID
AT THE VERY BEGINNING OF THE
SEGMENT, LARA TRUMP IS NOW
THE NEWEST MEMBER OF THE FOX
NEWS FAMILY.
AINSLEY: WELCOME TO THE FAMILY,
LARA.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS SO GREAT TO
BE WITH YOU.